نعم هذه الجلسه كانت جلسه يعني غاضبه جدا
خالد من النواب من مجلس النواب الاردني
تجاه التصريحات العنصريه والتي وصفتها
الحكومه الاردنيه بانها حاقده وانه تصرف
ارعن من وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي الذي
صدرت عنه تصريح تصريحات عنصريه جدا تجاه
الاردن والشعب الفلسطيني واستخدم خارطه
مزعومه تضم الحدود الاردنيه بالاضافه الى
الاراضي الفلسطينيه بالفعل صوت مجلس
النواب بالاجماع على طرد السفير
الاسرائيلي من الاردن وكما تعلم خالد هذه
التوصيه ليست ملزمه للحكومه الاردنيه
ولكنها تعبر عن غضب الشارع الاردني وتعبر
عن قرار مجلس النواب بان وجود السفير
الاسرائيلي في عمان غير مرغوب به لحين ان
تحل هذه المشكله ولحين ان يصدر تصدر يعني
تبرا واضح من الحكومه الاسرائيليه من
تصريحات وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي انا كنت
تحدثت قبل عشر دقائق من الان مع مصدر داخل
مجلس الوزراء الارد واكد لي بان الحكومه
الاردنيه تدرس بجديه كبيره هذه التوصيه من
مجلس النواب الاردني بان الحكومه الاردنيه
تتابع مع الدول العربيه والمجتمع الدولي
هذا الموقف الذي يعتبر خطير وخطير جدا
وخصوصا استخدام هذه الخارطه المزعومه وان
الاردن يطالب بموقف واضح من الحكومه
الاسرائيليه بان تتبرا بشكل واضح وصريح من
تصريحات الوزير الاسرائيلي المستفزه وكما
تعلم خالد نحن على ابواب شهر رمضان
المبارك وبالتالي الموقف ربما يحمل تصعيد
من الشارع الاردني